ليلة أخرى من الاشتباكات العنيفة في
وسط بيروت
هذا المساء هناك تتمحور هنا ،
دعنا نقترب قليلاً هناك تتمحور
حول أحد الطرق المؤدية إلى
مجلس النواب اللبناني الموجود
هنا خلف مدفع المياه
وهنا المتاريس التي كانت طوال
المساء  محور هذه الاشتباكات
رأينا زجاجات حارقة تُلقى على
قوات الأمن التي ترد
بالرصاص المطاطي بخراطيم المياه والغاز المسيل للدموع
وإلقاء بعض الحجارة
بأنفسهم الآن يبدو أن المتظاهرين
قد تم دفعهم إلى الوراء نتيجة
الاستخدام الكثيف للغاز المسيل للدموع.  هذا
يوم آخر في ما يسمى بأسبوع
الغضب الذي شهد مجموعة متنوعة من
الاشتباكات ، وهنا يتأرجح
نرى الآن قوات الأمن تنتشر
هنا بعد ساعات عندما احتشدوا
خلف تلك الحواجز مساء يوم السبت.
دعا الرئيس ميشال عون الجيش والأجهزة الأمنية
إلى فرض النظام لكن يبدو
أنهم استغرقوا وقتاً طويلاً لفعل ذلك.
الآن نرى هؤلاء أفرادًا من
الجيش اللبناني
الذين بقي معظمهم في مكانهم ولكن الآن بعد ساعات من
الاشتباكات ،
ما نسمعه من المتظاهرين هو
أنه بعد أكثر من ثلاثة أشهر من
الاحتجاجات السلمية إلى حد كبير  لقد
قرروا إلى حد ما اتخاذ تكتيك مختلف
لاستخدام المزيد من العنف خلال
الأيام القليلة الماضية رأيناهم يهاجمون
البنوك منذ فترة قصيرة رأيناهم
يكسرون نوافذ إحدى
شركات الهاتف الخلوي الرئيسية هنا
الشلل السياسي  تواصل مساء الأحد
التقى رئيس الوزراء المكلف حسن أبو
مع رئيس لبنان لإجراء
مزيد من المشاورات لتشكيل
حكومة ، ولكن حتى لو
شكلت الحكومات الأزمة الاقتصادية والمالية الأساسية في لبنان
، والتي أدت إلى اندلاع
الكثير من هذه الاحتجاجات ، فلا يبدو أن
أيًا من السياسيين لم يحل.
لقد توصلوا إلى أي أفكار حول كيفية
حلها ، أنا بن ويدمان مراسلة سي إن إن
من وسط بيروت